and in your opinion what is the greatest
threat to the royal family I think the
greatest threat is is most probably
difficult to kind of pinpoint if you
look at the threat with regards to
um the single cause issue people who
wish to use the world's media for an
event to highlight their events such as
the anti-monarchist movement or indeed
just stop oil with regards to
actions of a demonstrator they could be
very similar to the actions of a
terrorist carrying an IED in a rucksack
you know they jump across the barriers
and they start to run towards the Royal
carriage
okay they're only going to unfold a
banner
but at that pivotal moment you don't
know what they're going to do and you
know the pressure on
police officers to get that decision
right to arm police officers to get that
decision right
could have severe consequences